all week long we are opening up the et
vault and celebrating Brad's evolution
today the 90s in Brad's first ET
interview how do you mean
38:22 14 I don't know so how does Brad
feel about seeing himself just 26 years
old we have that here for you and I want
you to hear what you said what exactly
my real name is Brad Pitt yeah big goals
everyone once we take him seriously to
an extent I was talking about but I like
that do you feel like Mickey Rourke film
saying at the Mickey Rourke bandana
going
Brad's breakout role was in Thelma in
Louise take that cash you put in that
bag right there you got an amazing story
tell your friends it's tough when
Thummim Louise and there's little Geena
Davis rolling around scene right I see
my mom kind of girls livin he arrived to
the premiere with his first high-profile
girlfriend Juliette Lewis throughout the
90s Brad landed 17 film roles
yes that really is Brad singing and
Johnny suede here he is rehearsing the
director tells us we did about four
takes and remember Brad in cool world in
the flesh Fight Club
legends of the fall interview with the
vampire and a river runs through it
solidified Pitt's place as a hot leading
man well I'm sorry about that
that was my flaw your name comes up on
the screen and the squeals just started
I mean who's gonna complain you're
kidding me
I mean listen you go through all the
high school try to get that Brad's next
famous girlfriend was his seven co-star
Gwyneth Paltrow and they sure like to
match my a married William O Train
by 96 Brad popped the question yes I got
engaged that's one of the greatest
moments of my life when I talked to her
she said I want a lot of kids I guess
can be a dad with a lot of kids they
never ended up getting married and Brad
wouldn't become a dad until Angelina but
he did close out the decade dating the
friend who would become his first wife
I'm by the way Jennifer and Brad's love
story also turned into an infamous love
triangle as we know but tomorrow we dive
into the decade that was Brad and Jen
and then Brad and Angelina
[Music]